hello everyone i am claire golnick i am
co-founder and cto of fathom data
i'm here to talk to you today about
designing data products for life and
death decisions
now ultimately this is a talk about our
data infrastructure
but our data infrastructure is informed
by our tech strategy
and our tech strategy is informed by our
broader mission and so in order to give
you enough of the why as to why we made
the architecture choices that we did i'm
going to have to start with the problem
that we're trying to solve
fathom
is looking to simplify access to
biomanufacturing data
biomanufacturing data is process data
it is the records that are kept the
observations that are collected while a
new drug is on the manufacturing floor
and this data is critical because it is
the data that is used to answer the
question
is this batch of drugs
safe for release to patients
now if it sounds a little weird to use
manufacturing data to answer a safety
question
that's a little bit fair
but the perspective you have to realize
is that for the vast majority of drugs
that are manufactured on a day-to-day
basis
they have already gone through a
regulatory approval process
they have been approved and have gone
through a clinical trial so the question
of safety
is not
as much one about newly discovering if
the drug is safe but about generalizing
that inference about saying is this new
batch of drugs that we just manufactured
the same or similar enough
to the batch of drugs that we
manufactured during the clinical trial
to say that if we released it to
patients it would be just as
safe um so it becomes a question of
equivalence are these two things the
same and that feels like a uh
a pretty simple question to answer but
it's actually incredibly complicated and
unsolved
yes there are some cases in which after
a batch of new drugs is manufactured you
can run a suite of tests an assay and
you can say yes
this drug product or this drug substance
existed in this drug product at this
concentration at this specific purity
and if you're capable of doing that then
that means that your drug is likely a
small molecule like ibuprofen that's up
on the screen right there
but if you have any of the more new or
novel types of biologics that are now
coming to the market you no longer have
a simple test that you can do after the
fact
if you have a protein for example you
can have identical chemical structures
but if the protein is not folded it does
not have the three-dimensional structure
in the same way it doesn't have the same
bioactivity
or if you're delivering a cell therapy
not only do we not have a functional
assay to determine if two cells are the
same no one is asserting that any two
cells are the same
every two cells that come together are
different and so every time we deliver
them
to a patient we sort of have to ask are
these functionally equivalent living
organisms and we don't have a definition
for that
and even in cases where the active
ingredient is pretty simple perhaps like
an rna you can sometimes run into
problems with stability where the
half-life of the drug is so is so short
and it degrades so quickly that in order
to say is this drug the same is it
active you might have to push your
quality decisions all the way out onto
the edge past the distribution and away
from the manufacturing floor
um
so
uh this is a really complicated problem
the industry knows about it this is not
news to anyone working in biopharma and
they have a solution to it and their
solution is to say the process is the
product
as long as i manufacture things in
exactly the same way then i can be sure
that i'm delivering the same product and
the way that i convince myself
my patients and the fda that i'm
delivering this safe and effective
product is is to prove that i have
control over the process and so this
process data the manufacturing data is
critical for making these batch release
decisions that determine whether a drug
is safe for patients
now fathom's a new relatively new
company and we're really interested in
this process data and one of the reasons
you might imagine that we are interested
in it is because we are planning on
automating this batch release decision
that we are going to say okay we've
collected all the data and now we know
objectively that this this batch of
drugs is safer release
but fathom is not trying to automate
that decision
and one of the major reasons we're not
trying to automate that decision is
because we fundamentally don't believe
that data is objective
now or at least
data is not inherently objective it's
not innately objective
um
and sure sometimes data can be objective
but it has to meet certain conditions
and one of those conditions that must be
met in order for data to be objective
is that all stakeholder holders must
agree on the objective
and forever hard all of us in this room
know it is to keep a data set up to date
trying to keep a large group of people
aligned that's a whole different story
but again the question we're talking
about right here is we're trying to
deliver safe and effective drugs to
patients
so how is it possible that we have a
stakeholder that doesn't agree with this
objective like wouldn't it just be
obvious that everyone wants to do this
well this is where it gets
tricky because an objective
is really easy to get an alignment on if
you only say the rosy part if you only
say the easy part of the objective we're
all trying to save lives everyone's
going to agree to that but what is hard
about making a stable and reliable and
robust decision system is gaining
alignment on what you do in a
marginalized use case or a marginalized
decision and that's because the
stakeholders often don't agree on the
cost of a failure and in medicine this
arises every day all the time there's
often this tension between individual
ideal outcomes and what is good for the
collective or maintaining trust public
trust in our system of medicine this
happens all the time but in a specific
batch release decision this might happen
if a new batch of let's say a cell
therapy is being manufactured and during
that something goes wrong with the
process
let's say it gets contaminated some
bacteria grow in with the cells the
cells are not as healthy as they needed
to be or they would have been if they
had been used as part of a clinical
trial do you release this batch
most regulatory agencies looking out for
the collective good are going to say no
because i can't let a potentially
contaminated batch of drugs out into the
public
but right at that moment there are
patients who are sick who are suffering
and who are potentially terminally ill
who potentially by the time a new batch
is
is manufactured will no longer be
treatable perhaps their disease has
progressed so far that there is no
recovery they value their time
so much more and so much differently
than the people who are making a
decision for the collective good
and so
this is an ethical decision
and it's not a place for fathom to
operate
so what are we doing instead
we believe that data is a tool that
different stakeholders can use to make
different objectives
and so we clean data
and we do qa on data we make sure our
product is great
so that our customers have an easier
time making their own quality decisions
for their own products
and so we write a lot of data cleaning
algorithms but when we write those data
cleaning algorithms we are taking the
lessons we learned about what it means
to use data objectively and that key
lesson
is that
how your algorithm fails and what
happens when it fails
is the very first thing you should think
about before an algorithm goes into a
system
and we put constraints
and requirements
on any algorithm that goes into our
system and one of the constraints that
we put on it which is a little bit
counter-intuitive is that we ask our
algorithms to
fail sometimes to fail visibly loudly
but sometimes to fail intentionally
in a situation where they maybe could
make a good guess and maybe that guess
would even be right 90 of the time
but that extra 10 of the time the
consequences of that mistake would be
too high to be worth putting out an
answer
so we make our algorithms a little less
good
than they potentially could be based on
the tech or based on the data but we do
that strategically because we understand
the cost of failure
in our use case
um
but what's cool
about this
is that
when you assume failure or even
encourage failure you get some really
cool data architectures coming out
um and our system has to be
be designed from day one to be robust to
our algorithms our systems and our data
pipelines failing and so that means we
can't at any point put anything where
there's a single point of failure or
where there would be a cascading failure
and instead our entire system is
designed with distributed
redundant sometimes
data pipelines that are all asking a
small part of the question and voting on
their own specific small part of the
problem
um and this actually creates
a lot of engineering headache on like
the first two weeks this system is
deployed but longer term it creates a
much more robust system because
everything is engineered to not assume
anything else worked
and to make its best guess
given the information that is available
at the time when it needs to make a
decision
now what you might see on the end there
is a big black box that looks like a
single point of failure but even in our
data store
we're actually in order to maintain
auditability
um we're actually maintaining separate
layers
of our data
now it's pretty hard to get an intuition
really fast on what biological layers
might look like so instead to get an
idea of what a layered model is um
a really commonly understood layered
model is that of a map
where you potentially have
uh you know land masses and water masses
at the bottom and then cities and
countries and buildings and traffic and
each of these different layers they have
different levels of reliability right
like yes technically the continents are
moving
but i probably don't have to include
that in my model because it'll be good
enough right so there's some level of
base high performing algorithms and then
you can get your more and more robust
potentially potentially more error-prone
algorithms on the top
and because
we don't combine these layers
when we store it we get to combine them
at query time
and what's cool about that is
at the time in which we query our data
we know who is querying our data which
means that we can dynamically construct
the world as they view it there isn't a
single source of truth because everyone
looks at the world differently and
they're going to look at different
things and want a different
representation of that data
so this has been a little abstract
so we're going to go very concrete into
the world of what actual
biomanufacturing data looks like
and
maybe you might be surprised to know
that it looks like a piece of paper
because that's where pharma is right now
almost all their data is stored on paper
and so when we get a new piece of paper
into our system to analyze we are
deconstructing it just like you saw like
we talked about and we are analyzing
this piece of paper and we might analyze
it in many different layers and look at
it from many different perspectives in
order to make inferences about how we
should clean harmonize standardize this
data
for example if you get rid of all the
words and you just look at the lines
you'll notice that a lot of
relationships are actually maintained in
information about relationships between
different data so even when you don't
know what the data is at all you know
that a relationship in the same column
is related
to another piece of data that is in the
same column and so you can start getting
this idea of how your data and how your
schema is represented even without
having any access to the text at all
and then perhaps you can look at the
layer with the text alone and you can
make different inferences you can infer
and look and identify where all the
dates are and ask yourself what can i
learn about that or you might throw an
nlp model on there do some content
analysis in order to group and organize
data
um you can do all of these different
things but they're all done in parallel
and separate from each other they are
not we are not trying to push them all
into one giant model in order to
understand this data set
so what does it look like to dynamically
reconstruct different people's worldview
at query time
way moving way down and away from the
life and depth decision of if if a bat
should be released into like one of
those more practical work issues that
uh teams in bio operations tend to have
um you have two teams
uh on a
on a traditional operations team one
might be the manufacturing science team
and the other one is the quality team
and they have
different goals
right they have different objectives the
manufacturing science team is going to
look at how their process is doing over
time they want to see like you know if i
started incubating myself at a slightly
different temperature or if i used a
different ph buffer what did it matter
and so they're going to be really
looking at the content of the data
while the quality team needs to ask each
is each individual batch did it happen
exactly the way that the process had
aligned and so they're going to looking
for any specific anomaly or deviation on
that batch so if you look at something
simple like this
crossout right here
to the manufacturing team they're only
going to be interested in the corrected
version of this data
the one where someone crossed it out and
then wrote something on top to them that
is the only piece of data that matters
the other one might not exist right and
so you want to be able to represent that
world view to them when they ask for the
data you want to be able to say
yes this is what this number was on this
batch this is what the cell viability
was
but the quality team is going to be able
to want to ask hey how many times did
somebody cross this number out
because for a couple reasons we might be
looking for fraud we may be needing to
retrain our team we might need to be
needing to do a lot of different
inferences uh and to make sure that our
any if this was resulted in a deviation
that it was handled and documented
appropriately for the fda
and so because we maintain and keep and
model our data as all these separate
different pieces we can represent these
different world views on the same set of
data
so
in closing
a couple ways of which how uh how
fathoms perspective on data and the fact
that data is is not objective inherently
in and of itself um plays into how we
build our data teams and data
architectures
uh the first is that we believe that
data is a tool
um and that we can use that tool to do
many different things but that does not
mean we know everything right we're very
careful about where we should be making
decisions and where we should not
um
we believe that algorithms always make
mistakes no matter what we do
and so sometimes we should make them
make mistakes
and that the broader ecosystem in which
you introduce your product to these
customers they should be aware that your
algorithm should make mistakes too and
it should be exposed to them so that
they can correct it and it becomes part
of their understanding and their
interaction with the product as well
um
and then understanding that
what happens when your algorithm fails
is probably one of the most important
assumptions you can discuss before you
even start building something it is
incredibly powerful um and then the last
one is sort of just a small thing but we
talk a lot about single sources of truth
um
and i really think we should start
thinking about being open to keeping
multiple copies of the same data because
there isn't only one way to look at the
world
um and
redundancy is a critical part of how you
build resilient and robust systems and
so i think we should look into that a
little more and
if any of this is interesting to you and
this is how you like to think about data
you should come talk to me because we're
looking for some great people for our
team
so thank you
[Applause]
you